two better eastern division rivals have
traveled over 2 500 miles to paradise
we are in san diego california it is a
beautiful monday night at petco park
looking forward to this one it's the
2020 american league division series
i mean just an outstanding start against
the blue jays in fact that whole tampa
bay team only allowed
three runs to the blue jays in two games
but you see his numbers from
young year but also his last start he
looked like he did
in 2018. so it'll be at least a nine
pitch at-bat to start it for blake snell
there's no jumping off point with the
new york yankees
and a shot back up the middle of base
head
well that at-bat tells you all you need
to know about
where the yankees are is the lineup
right now the savages are back according
to their manager aaron boone
le mayhew at third baseman aaron hicks
stepping in the switch hitter here today
for the yankees and on the first pitch
in the air
left center plenty deep to score lemay
hue
here meyer will haul it in and that
first inning scoreless streak
is over for blake's now le mayhew steps
on the plate the yankees are on the
board first
and the former astro signed the big nine
year deal
this past offseason astro turned yankee
garrett cole gets the ball for game one
in this american league division series
the number one man in this tampa bay
lineup brandon lau
and a swing out of miss a foul tip into
the mitt
of higashiyoka to strike out the first
for garrett colt
rosarina hits third for this tampa bay
ball club
and he rips one into center field that
had good wood on it hicks
he's going back he's at the wall as
she's gone
randy rosarina squares it at one with a
booming home run to center field he has
some thunder in his back
tori has had a great series against the
indians and that two gamer had five hits
here's a 2-2 and that's in there a call
strike three got a generous call
backwards k for blake snell at a one two
three inning
clint frazier leading off and he jumps
on a pitch that is way back how far is
that one gonna fly
clint frazier sends one out of here
two one yankees and a guy who has not
played in a major league game in eight
days
delivers a bomb of a home run here at
petco
two to the count on zunino and a wave at
a miss
cole wipes him out higashiyoka secures
it over at first base
there is out number one two gone for
brandon lau
and cole deals and a swaying adam has
put it right by him at 99 miles an hour
garrett cole after frazier gives the
yankees the lead is shut down inning one
two three the rays
go in order infield shift is on three on
the left side two and two the count
ready for a 2-2 and a swing out of his
he got him
[Applause]
snell with his second strikeout and now
two men are out
two runners in scoring position here's
gleber torres torres see if he has a
green light
he takes and it's ball four so torres
will reach that'll load the bases
and here comes clint frazier now
and a swing and a foul tip into the mitt
of zunino
a strikeout for blake snell that's a big
out mark that one
that sets up g-man choi now yeah that
ball's hit hard in the left center field
that is way back
and g-man has someone out of here
two-run blast for g-man choi
and just like that the tampa bay rays
are on top
three to two kyla gashioka will
lead off get through this that ball is
ripped deep in the
left field that is way back and gone
long home run from the bottom of the
order
kyle lagashioka goes deep and we're all
tied at three
for tampa bay that balls rip judge into
left field and whistles one out of
aaron judge a frozen rope into the seats
yankees are back on top 4-3
judge wasting no time and hits a missile
out of here
so they're loaded up here with two outs
here it comes it's a fast ball at 100
he strikes him out garrett cole just
kept climbing the ladder
two outs kiermeier payoff pitch coming
with two away and a swing at a miss cole
strikes out kiermeier eight punch outs
and three of his last four outs are via
the k
britain fires 2-2 is swung on and missed
britain with a big strikeout adamus down
swinging the yankees are thinking about
a knockout punch right here
there he comes and a line shot into
center field
higashiyoka is going to be waved home
kiermeier's got a great arm the throw to
the plate the tag
and he's safe the ball in and out of the
glove of perez
big hit and an rbi for aaron hicks and
the yankees add to their lead it's 5-3
and then load it up with one out forge
on carlos stem curtis deals
standing in the air center field deep on
the run
by running out of room and she's gone
it's a grand slam for giancarlo stanton
a game breaker for stan in the yankees
you know you got to give him a mulligan
for the way that start happening with
the weather and the wind
and the rain well that's it lao strikes
out
sesame finishes the job and the new york
yankees win game one